gestalten und verteidigen muss
demokratie jeden tag aufs neue belebt
werden mehr demokratie wagen
mitmachen mitreden mitdenken damit
demokratie nicht nur theorie und idee
bleibt reichlich anregungen liefern die
dokumentationen bei phoenix auch online
und in den mediatheken von ard und zdf
[Musik]
jetzt live aus köln
der presseclub mit allen
hallo und herzlich willkommen zu diesem
vierten kriegs wochenende des
angriffskriegs von russland gegen die
ukraine wir haben es gerade in der
tagesschau um 12 uhr gesehen die
grausamkeiten die angriffe vor ort gehen
mit unverminderter härte weiter und aus
gegebenen anlass möchte ich ganz aktuell
in das land schalten zu meinem kollegen
norbert hahn im griff er ist in der west
ukraine
norbert was können sie denn über die
aktuelle situation im land berichten
jan schlimmsten sieht es ganz klar in
mario pohl aus die schwer umkämpfte
stadt und schwarzem meer und
soll eine kunst schule getroffen worden
seien heute mit 400 menschen die dort
schutz gesucht haben ältere frauen
kinder vor allen dingen die nachrichten
kommen ganz spärlich alles was wir
wissen müssen wir im grunde über eine
ein tweet in einem messenger-dienst von
einem stadtrat
ja es ist ein bisschen so wie bei dem
beschuss des theaters in maria mario
pohl vor ein paar tagen auch da wissen
wir nicht wie viele menschen sind jetzt
tagelang unter dem schutt begraben wie
viele menschen kamen raus gibt es tote
gibt es verletzte die stadt ist
abgeschnitten in den straßen wird
gekämpft schon relativ dicht ans zentrum
also mario pohl ist im moment hier
wirklich der hotspot um den sich alles
dreht und andere landesteile werden auch
angegriffen immer wieder auch um die
warum tut sich viel aber vor allen
dingen mario pohl ist im moment schwer
unter beschuss und wenn man hier mit den
menschen spricht dann hört man immer
wieder das gleiche die situation ist
herzzerreißend alles guckt auf diese
stadt im moment
norbert wir haben ja auch jetzt erneut
berichte gehört der russischen seite
dass wieder eine hyperschall rakete zum
einsatz gekommen sein soll oder mehrere
was können sie darüber sagen
ja also erstmal muss man der russischen
seite da glauben wenn man das möchte
gestern ist eine rakete eingeschlagen
150 kilometer südlich hiervon griff in
einem munitionsdepot heute sollte eine
zweite hyperschall rakete eingesetzt
worden sei gegen ein treibstofflager in
nikolajew das liegt ungefähr in der
region auch wie mario pohl also im
südosten des landes ja man muss da den
russen trauen oder man man kann das
eigentlich nur tun war es wirklich eine
hyper sonic müsse das wissen wir nicht
wenn es eine wahl dann ist es in der tat
der einsatz einer neuen waffe im krieg
die russen haben
2018 gesagt putin 2018 gesagt man habe
so eine waffe entwickelt sie sah
einsatzbereit und ja das ist jetzt
möglicherweise der erste einsatz gewesen
überschallgeschwindigkeit heißt es sind
raketen die in diesem fall in dieser
fall von dieser kim schaal so heißt die
auf russisch durch raketen die bis zu 16
kilometer pro sekunde zurücklegen können
die damit extrem schwer abzufangen sind
und die im grunde ja eine neue stufe
darstellen könnten in der rüstung ja
vielen dank norbert hahn live aus löw im
westen der ukraine für diese
einschätzung
und damit gehen wir in unserer runde
hier im presseclub wir haben verstanden
es ist ein unvorstellbarer krieg den wir
jetzt hier gerade erleben auch die
reaktionen des westens waren bis dahin
unvorstellbar finanz und
wirtschaftssanktionen eine nie
dagewesene einigkeit in der eu die nato
prüft ihre ostflanke zu verstärken doch
all das hat bislang den russischen
präsidenten wladimir putin nicht
beeindruckt trotz des stockenden
vormarsches der russischen armee hat er
vorgestern noch mal sein volk auf einen
militärischen sieg in der ukraine
eingeschworen deshalb das thema des
presseclubs heute kampf ums überleben
wie kann der westen die ukraine
unterstützen und ich freue mich auf
diese gäste begrüßte ganz herzlich nana
brink sie ist freie autorin unter
anderem für den deutschlandfunk und
stellvertretende vorsitze von louis de
women in international security einem
netzwerk von frauen in der außen- und
internationalen sicherheitspolitik in
deutschland
herzlich willkommen auch johanna marie
us-dollar xi ist publizistin und
leiterin des warschauer büros der
heinrich böll stiftung
ich begrüße auch klaus geiger in der
runde er ist ressortleiter der
außenpolitik bei der welt und herzlich
willkommen stephan stuchlik er ist ein
korrespondent in berlin für
verteidigungs- und sicherheitspolitik
war zuvor auch korrespondent in brüssel
und moskau herrscht liegt mit ihnen
möchte ich gerne anfangen sie haben in
den vergangenen zwei wochen auch sehr
viel russisches programm konsumiert
fernsehen den ganzen tag und haben die
lage in der ukraine bei uns im ersten in
langen einschätzungen verfolgt es gab ja
jetzt in dieser nacht auch noch mal eine
videobotschaft des ukrainischen
präsidenten selensky der sich sowohl an
das eigene volk aber auch an die russen
gewandt hat wie erklären sie sich dass
das bei der russischen bevölkerung so
wenig davon rüberkommt von diesem jetzt
fast vier wochen dauernden krieg von den
verlusten die die russische armee ja
auch schon erfahren haben muss wie
erklären sie sich das ich glaube man
muss sich zum ersten klarmachen dass die
russische taktik immer sehr zynisch es
auf dem schlachtfeld ich habe selber
2008 in diesem georgienkrieg ein
bisschen beobachten können wie das
funktioniert da gehen gefallene der
russischen seite nicht zurück wieder ins
heimatland sondern die werden da so
schlimm es klingen mag auf der straße
liegen gelassen oder mit mobilien
krematorium verbrannt das heißt da ist
im prinzip schon der gedanke im kopf die
bilder dürfen auf gar keinen fall zu
schlimm sein sonst würde man an der
heimatfront so sagen die russen das ja
möglicherweise den informationskrieg
verlieren und man muss sich vor augen
halten dass ein großteil der russischen
bevölkerung sich immer noch über das
fernsehen informiert wir haben eine
relativ große bevölkerung auf dem land
für dieses fernsehen dass die nummer
eins und da werden sämtliche russischen
verluste beziehungsweise auch sämtlichen
bildern die möglicherweise darauf
hinweisen können dass da was schief
gelaufen ist systematisch rausgelassen
und das ist so ein topf mit dem deckel
im moment noch relativ geschlossen wird
und die ukrainische seite sieht man
gerade gesagt theresa lenski hat
versucht das zu durchbrechen er spricht
auf russisch zu ihnen und es gibt auch
diese aktion bitte liebe trainer ruft
eure verwandten in russland an und sagt
den wie schlimm es eigentlich ist und
wir sehen letzter satz noch dazu dass in
belarus wo ja im prinzip das hinterland
ist für die für bestimmte russische
aktion den leuten in den krankenhäusern
belarussen verboten wird darüber zu
sprechen was wir im zustand russische
soldaten wieder zurückkommen also da ist
sehr sehr viel druck drauf wie lange er
noch halten wird wage ich nicht zu
prognostizieren
postulat vielleicht auch noch mal zu
dieser seelands die rede jetzt also er
wendet sich ja zum zweiten mal bewusst
an das russische volk heute gestern
nacht hat er ihn im wesentlichen gesagt
so und so viele soldaten sind schon
gestorben das wird ganze generationen
brauchen um diese verluste wieder
aufzubauen wie wird das gerade in polen
wahrgenommen weil das ist ja ein land
was extrem nah und extrem gefährdet im
moment auch ist die polnische seite
wundert sich so ein bisschen über die
untätigkeit des westens ganz ehrlich
gesagt
man hat ja schon
glücklich hat ja den georgien-krieg
gewinn 2008 in 2008 spätestens da haben
die polen gesagt pass auf putin will ja
keinen wird halt nicht machen in
georgien wird weiter gehende verstorbene
präsident lech kaczynski hat ja damals
schon gesagt die nächste sei die ukraine
mann hatte auf diese warnungen nicht
gehört man das als panisch art
panikartig abgetan man hat es also los
hob abgetan und jetzt könnte man
eigentlich nur sagen wir haben euch ja
gesagt dass putin gemeingefährlich ist
und dass er eben weiter gehen würde von
daher man solidarisiert sich extrem wie
die ukraine sein nachbarland
kulturgeschichtlich verbunden und man
wie gesagt man ist enttäuscht von dem
westen das hier gar keine keine richtige
klare kante gezeigt wird es geht ja
nicht darum dass da jetzt truppen der
nato einmarschieren in der ukraine aber
dass man trotzdem auch sei es symbolisch
eine solidarität zeigt wie eben zum
beispiel nach der nach der rede von
salewski im bundestag da haben alle sehr
vermisst dass da wenigstens zehn minuten
oder fünf minuten
ruhe ist schweigeminute für die
kriegsopfer irgendwelche symbolische
gäste die gerade in der kriegszeit
aussenpolitik auch ausmacht dass man
eben diese gesten macht sie haben die
enttäuschung angesprochen das ist ein
ganz guter moment wir haben uns auch
einen o ton aus der rede mal raus
geschnitten von herrn selensky im
bundestag das war am donnerstag hören
wir mal rein was er gesagt hat
roller dragon hat gesagt reißen sie
diese mauer ein und das sage ich nun
ihnen kanzler scholz reißen sie diese
mauer nieder
geben sie deutschland die führungsrolle
die es verdient
das war tatsächlich eine sehr emotionale
rede des iranischen präsidenten sie
lenski er passt ja seine interventionen
auch immer so ein bisschen an das
publikum an in den usa hat er auch eine
rede vor dem kongress gehalten und
danach hat der us-präsident beiden
angekündigt zusätzliche militärhilfe
waffenlieferungen in höhe von 800
millionen us dollar herr geiger im sie
wissen was deutschland bislang zugesagt
hat und sie wissen auch was deutschland
bislang geliefert hat wie bewerten sie
da die rolle im moment ja das ist so
ähnlich wie first solar act gesagt hat
es geht nicht nur darum ob wir jetzt
hier reingehen in den krieg und den
dritten welt registrieren es geht schon
auch um haltung und um gesten und um
bestimmte dinge die signalisieren wir
nehmen diesen konflikt ernst und wir
stehen auf der seite der ukraine jetzt
haben wir wachen geliefert
500 stinger raketen zuerst und 500.000
panzerfäuste das ging relativ schnell
nach der rede von olaf scholz und dann
haben wir jetzt drei wochen gewartet
drei wochen in denen menschen in der
ukraine gestorben sind und dann haben
jetzt noch mal 500 verschimmelte hätte
fast gesagt strehler raketen aus ddr
beständen geliefert wo man einig 2700
zugesagt hat
gleichzeitig trainieren land und das
wird oft übersehen dass der viertgrößte
waffenexporteur der welt ist wir haben
unternehmen ohne ende wenn man einfach
mal das geld nehmen wird und da hingehen
und sagen gebt uns die neuen die besten
und wir geben sie der ukraine auf die
idee ist noch gar keiner gekommen bei
der bundesregierung oder was ich höre
sind sie darauf gekommen
aber auch da hat man jetzt vier wochen
ungefähr verstreichen lassen tut nichts
da kann ich sagen seitenwände
verschlafen es scheint ja so zu sein
dass morgen bundeskanzler olaf scholz
sich explizit mit der frage was braucht
denn die bundeswehr jetzt und was kaufen
wir vielleicht wird dabei ja auch
diskutiert was sollten wir vielleicht
für die ukraine kaufen wissen wir jetzt
noch nichts darüber also hör schöntag 26
es morgen vom krieg tag sänger mal mit
einer prüfung anfangen
vielleicht frau bringt möchte ich sie
auch gern in die runde rein holen wir
haben ja gerade die deutschen
waffenlieferungen thematisiert wir haben
aber ja auch in dem gespräch mit norbert
hahn eben gehört die berichte über einen
einsatz von hyperschall raketen durch
die russische seite
jetzt frage ich sie mal auch als
militärexperte
ganz doof ist der krieg damit in eine
neue phase getreten also scheint
russland jetzt doch eben stärkeres
waffenarsenal zur anwendung bringen zu
wollen und dann daran angeknüpft die
frage was bringen dann ich sag mal jetzt
deutsche flugabwehrraketen oder was man
da liefern kann wenn solche
hochtechnologisierten ultraschnellen
waffen angewendet werden also ich finds
wahnsinnig interessant dass die es jetzt
getan haben wobei wir ja noch nicht ganz
genau wissen ob sie es wirklich getan
haben also diese beweise die müsste man
dann auch noch kriegen ich warne so ein
bisschen davor zu sagen dass das eine
brandneue waffe ist also man muss immer
aufpassen dass man auch nicht der
russischen propaganda auf dem leim geht
das ist mit sicherheit eine waffe sie
haben es ja erklärt die eine enorme
geschwindigkeit hat die auch dadurch
eine enorme durchschlagskraft hat und
das entscheidende ist dass sie im
gegensatz zu
interkontinentalraketen dies ja auch
gibt also diese reichweiten sind jetzt
keine wirklich neue erfindung sie kann
ihren flug ändern ja das können
interkontinentalrakete nicht das heißt
sie können intelligent reagieren auf
bestimmte bedrohungen können ein radar
aussetzen so also wie viel davon in den
russischen beständen sind das entzieht
sich wirklich mein erkenntnis ich wüsste
gerne auch jemanden der da wirklich
profunde darüber ausgehen kann aber in
der tat sagt es für mich vor allen
dingen eines weil was mich die ganze
zeit wundert an diesem krieg ist ja dass
die russische lufthoheit über der
ukraine ja nicht wirklich hergestellt
ist also man hätte ja eigentlich gedacht
es gibt einen schnellen angriff und es
sei eigentlich kein problem dass so eine
supermacht eigentlich ganz schnell es
schafft diesen luftraum eigentlich zu
überwachen das ist ja nicht passiert
insofern glaube ich dass das jetzt auch
ein teil der taktik ist die sich also
der strategie die sich geändert hat um
dann so ein taktisches mittel wie diese
hyperschall waffe irgendwie einzusetzen
um zu signalisieren passt auf wir haben
noch sachen in der hinterhand
ja also genau drauf gucken von tag zu
tag ich würde das nicht ausschließen
aber ich glaube nicht dass ich viel
davon im arsenal haben also kann ich mir
schwer vorstellen dann vielleicht auf
den zweiten teil meiner frage war ja
also sowohl was liefert deutschland
aktuell an waffen für die ukraine ist
das aus ihrer sicht ausreichend und wenn
ja würde es denn bei diesen neuen waffen
auch helfen ich meine die werden ja
nicht nur diese neuen daten einsetzen
wenn es denn stimmt dass die hyperschall
rakete zum einsatz kam sondern auch
konventionell weiter kämpfen wie sehen
sie da auch die deutsche position also
ich bin ein bisschen gespannt was morgen
da verhandelt wird auf dem waschzettel
muss ja die verteidigungsministerin
irgendwie haben was gebraucht wird dass
die bundeswehr nicht profunde sachen
liefern kann liegt eigentlich auf der
hand also die verteidigungsministerin
hat selbst gesagt wir haben nichts ja
also unsere mittel sind erschöpft und
wenn man sich vorstellt allein um die
bestände an munition eigentlich
aufzufüllen um die nato anforderungen zu
erfüllen bräuchte man schon 20
milliarden aber auf ihre frage
zurückzukommen
nein natürlich nicht also von
deutschlands gibt es ja die sind ja auch
schon verlegt worden allerdings nicht in
die ukraine sondern in die slowakei und
die amerikaner haben in ihrem paket der
800 millionen die jetzt neu
aufgemacht worden sind ganz klar auch
radarsysteme und ich denke das ist das
irgendwie entscheidende und schweres
gerät das es angekündigt aber bis das
dann wirklich auch vor ort es wird auch
noch einige zeit ins land gehen
vielleicht warten wir mal den blick
diese massiven waffenlieferungen die ja
auch von anderen staaten kommen nicht
nur von deutschland
wenn deutschland liefern würde wäre es
nicht sehr viel aber vor allem ja auch
die unterstützung durch die us waffen
wird sicherlich auch nächste woche beim
nato sondergipfel noch mal ein thema
sein und es ist ja ein besonderes
zeichen haben wir auch schon gehört dass
es im präsenz mit joe biden dem
amerikanischen präsidenten stattfindet
vielleicht einfach mal so von der
flughöhe ist das wirklich herr stück ein
treffen von dem man sagt das ist jetzt
das wichtigste dass die nato vielleicht
in ihrer geschichte aber jedenfalls in
den letzten jahren gemeinsam abgehalten
hat und was auf was was wird man dann
möglicherweise schließen oder
diskutieren ich werde mit diesen
superlativen erstmal ein bisschen
vorsichtig klar ist dass ich glaube
imbissen noch einen schritt zurückgehen
würde bei diesen kindern die haben ja
auch bei den russischen proben eigen
anscheinend nie so richtig gut
funktioniert und ich glaube nicht dass
das jetzt um das noch mal zu sagen eine
waffe ist die den krieg jetzt wirklich
grundsätzlich verändert der krieg wird
glaube ich ganz woanders entschieden
aber bei der nato wird wahrscheinlich
darauf ankommen wie wie stark hält diese
allianz jetzt zusammen und man wird auf
jeden fall versuchen ein zeichen der
geschlossenheit zu setzen obwohl man ja
schon einige buslinien sieht es gibt ja
staaten polen tschechien
slowenien
deren präsidentin
gereist sind nach kiew um gesagt haben
also wir brauchen einfach mehr nato
engagement und dann gibt es staaten auch
die bundesrepublik deutschland die
niederlande
eigentlich glaube ich die mehrheit
dieser ganz vorsicht an der
bahnsteigkante da sollte man auf keinen
fall hin treten wir riskieren einen
dritten weltkrieg und ich bin mir
relativ sicher dass
das noch klärungsbedarf gibt bei der
frage was ist denn eigentlich mit dieser
beistands klausel ab wann gilt die denn
da ist relativ große unklarheit in der
definition unabhängig von allem anderen
verstärkung der nato südflanke oben noch
einmal verstärkung irgendwie im baltikum
wird es um die frage gehen ab wann ist
die schwelle überschritten wo sich die
nato gezwungen sieht einzugreifen wäre
ein grosser cyberangriff zum beispiel
der ja auch in artikel 5 er erwähnt wird
auf warschau zum beispiel wäre das ein
eingriff szenario wäre eine von vielen
befürchtete biologische oder chemische
waffen einwendungen in der ukraine die
sich ja geografisch gar nicht begrenzen
lässt wäre das ein möglicher anlass um
einzugreifen und zu sagen jetzt ist die
nato angegriffen und ich glaube die
geschlossenheit und b eine definition
dessen ab wann die schwelle erreicht
wird das wird extrem wichtig seien und
deswegen glaube ich schon dass sich die
nato aber einige ihre regeln beugen wird
vielleicht dazu ganz gut unsere nutzer
in den sozialen medien auch
einzubeziehen wir haben ja den
presseclub auch auf twitter und wir
streamen ihn auf den plattformen die sie
kennen und unter anderem fragt marco
ertl auf facebook wozu
brauchen wir denn die nato wenn die sich
nicht traut gegen russland vorzugehen
für mich ist die zurückhaltung nicht
nachzuvollziehen und falsch sie haben ja
gerade beschrieben dass die rote grenze
eine wann ist eigentlich wirklich ein
mitgliedsland der nato angegriffen eine
offene ist die zu diskutieren ist
vielleicht an sie frau stoll arag die
frage gerade polen ist da ja so ein
bisschen in der vorreiterrolle sie haben
auch noch mal klar gemacht der vorschlag
der nato friedensmission die
vize-premier kaczynski ja schon klar
gemacht hat soll auch auf dem
sondergipfel noch mal diskutiert werden
das war eine forderung die er bei dieser
überraschungsreise nach kiew formuliert
hatte die wurde dann sofort vom tisch
gewischt nach dem motto
friedensmissionen hat das wort frieden
drin und so lange es keinen
waffenstillstand gibt gibt es keine
mission was verfolgt polen denn für ein
ziel damit das jetzt noch mal auf dem
nato sondergipfel zum platzieren man
hört in porn zu verzichten ist bei der
nato seit 23 jahren jetzt vor kurzem
wurde es in brünn gefeiert und man hört
ja bei jedem zweiten satz wirklich in
der polnischen politik in der polnischen
medien zum glück sind wir mitglied der
nato weil es bei den ländern wie polen
wie den baltischen staaten ist es
wirklich existenziell dass sie bei der
nato sind es geht ja um ihre nationale
souveränität
dass es gemeingefährlich ist nicht bei
der nato zu sein sieht man jetzt am
beispiel der ukraine wie es eben wenn
man
russischer nachbarn hat wie es ausgehen
kann
und in polen macht man sich hört man und
liest man und spürt man regelrecht
gedanken ob die nato dann wirklich
bereit wäre im fall eines falles wie sie
sagen dann zu helfen einzugreifen oder
wird es dann auf irgendwelche jetzt
zynisch gesagt sanktionen hinaus laufen
wird wird man polen wird man polen
allein lassen jetzt eine zeitschrift vor
drei tagen erschienen so ein
wochenzeitschrift ungefähr wie der
spiegel titelt droht uns ein atomkrieg
wird uns die nato helfen fragezeichen
also ist es etwas was durchaus in polen
diskutiert wird und wovon man angst hat
dass man eben allein gelassen wird es
werden ja auch so alte traumata
getriggert in polen muss man sagen also
die zeit des zweiten weltkrieges diese
unheimliche union zwischen russland und
deutschland und da setzen ganz viele
mechanismen auch ein dass es ja auch
etwa eine psychologische sache die grad
in polen und auch nicht nur in polen
sondern auch in diesen in diesen ländern
dazwischen sage ich jetzt passierte frau
bringt vielleicht an sie sich frage
genau wie wird denn die nato mit diesen
ängsten gerade der osteuropäischen
länder in zukunft umgehen aus ihrer sie
ich glaube das ist eine ganz ganz
schwierige frage und ich glaube es ist
jetzt der punkt wo man noch mal genau
nachfragt was heißt denn eine
weitergehende reaktion also ich glaube
man muss wirklich genau hingucken wenn
wir uns die friedensmission angucken die
hier vorgeschlagen worden ist bedeutet
das im westen der ukraine ja eigentlich
eine flugverbotszone einzurichten ein
korridor ja durch denen dann flüchtlinge
geflüchtete nach polen kommen können und
wie sie wörter zum beispiel material
hilfsgüter und auch waffen was heißt das
konkret ja so eine zone muss im
zweifelsfalle verteidigt werden das
heißt das ist eine militärische
option das ist keine friedensmission
also ich sag darf deshalb immer weil ich
glaube man muss die begriffe auch man
muss auch die das kind beim namen nennen
ja und wenn es eine militärische aktion
ist ja dann kann dass putin auch als
aggression empfinden ja er hat bislang
genau unterschieden zwischen nato
mitgliedern und nato mitgliedern und die
ukraine ist ein nicht nato-mitglied ich
weiß das ist sehr zynisch und ich stimme
ihnen zu recht mich also mich hat das
erschüttert dass der bundestag es nicht
geschafft hat nach dieser bewegenden
seelands geräte einfach aufzustehen und
zu sagen nicht nur beifall zu klatschen
sondern auch sympathie empathie und weiß
man das ist nicht so die sache des
bundeskanzlers aber bei den grünen hätte
ich mir das eigentlich schon erwartet
und ich verstehe dass er es mit dem
rücken zur wand r kämpft um sein
überleben ich glaube das würde jeder tun
wenn es um sein land geht trotzdem
ist die nato ja eine lebensversicherung
das heißt sie muss genau hingucken was
kann sie tun um nicht eine eskalation
ich mag das wort vom dritten weltkrieg
immer nicht weil das finde ich ist auch
russische propaganda also
man muss gucken was kann eine reaktion
unterhalb einer militärischen aktion
bedeuten und da und da stimme ich ihnen
nicht da ist soviel passiert also ich
meine an waffenlieferungen an sachen nur
man muss immer genau hingucken wann
verletzt sozusagen einen luftraum und
einen aufweisen sie man hätte deutsche
waffenlieferungen oder insgesamt
insgesamt da ist ja viel gelaufen
also ich habe vor allen dingen das
spreche ich auch von der deutschen von
der deutschen haltung insgesamt
großbritannien usa polen leicht
warum wenn du sie das gesagt übernehmen
sie eine führungsrolle und wir dürfen
nicht über hören was sie denn zum
schluss seiner rede gesagt hat wenn sie
sagen nie wieder wenn deutschland seit
80 jahren sagt nie wieder warum wenn
jetzt ein diktator mit nazi methoden die
freie welt angreift warum stellen wir
uns ganz hinten in den geleitzug nachdem
wir immer ganz vorne gestanden haben und
nie wieder gesagt haben und das ist doch
der punkt warum stehen wir nicht da eine
an der front wo zumindest die andern
natra gedanken zu grenze aber was wäre
dann denn ihre ihr vorschlag also was
hätten die doch also mein mann kann
natürlich zu rheinmetall gehen und kann
sagen ok auf unsere kosten produzieren
wer etwas um die vom gleichen die
ukraine etwas wären also das wäre mal
was erstes dass wir zumindest
waffenlieferungen im umfang haben die
auch andere westliche länder haben ja
die haben das durchgemacht putin
bombardiert man mal irgend einen
militärposten um wieder zu sagen tut das
nicht aber also wir müssen seinen platz
schon auch mal irgendwie ein bisschen
testen und nicht immer glauben zwei
schritte zurück bleiben weil wir glauben
dass er dann was ganz schlimmes macht ja
das ist sein kalkül und die anderen
westlichen länder zumindest und gerade
die mutigen osteuropäer die gehen
zumindest bis an die grenze aber wir
bleiben hinten in der etappe und machen
es uns gemütlich und das ist beschämend
für ein land mit unserer geschichte also
ich bin entschuldigung der sich da
einmal kurz widerspreche ich kann die
zurückhaltung der bundesregierung also
was waffenlieferungen immer noch angeht
kann ich die zum teil verstehen man hat
ja immer drei optionen die erste herren
sogenannte eskalation die will keiner
die 2000 waffenlieferung die dritte sind
wirtschaftssanktionen wenn wir jetzt bei
diesen waffen also sind sind drei
optionen die uns alle im prinzip treffen
würden also wenn man habe gehört hat
weiß man ja auch was
wirtschaftssanktionen für ein land wie
deutschland bedeuten bei unserer politik
der letzten zehn jahre absolut ja auch
der meinung man hätte sich irgendwie
nach der saal ins gerede einmaligen über
die vergangenheit unterhalten sollen die
er gewählt hat aber etwas was gerne
außer augen außer acht gelassen wird wir
finanzieren ja sehr viele europäische
union und haben der ukraine jetzt die
möglichkeit gegeben aus diesem european
passform im prinzip waffen direkt zu
kaufen ist natürlich die bundesregierung
nicht her geht und waffen direkt
geliefert da ist zum einen steht die
bundeswehr und ihre nicht sehr gute
verfassung dagegen wir haben eigentlich
nicht mehr wie sie erinnern sich an frau
berbalk die gesagt hat wenn ich zaubern
könnte würde ich war sehr bezaubernd und
wir versuchen das zu umgehen ich will
jetzt nicht irgendwie das bewerten aber
500 millionen sind 500 millionen und
wenn die ukraine damit auf dem freien
markt einkaufen kann und waffen
einkaufen kann so habe ich diesen titel
verstanden dann ist es mehr als nichts
da gebe ich ihnen recht also diese
european facility for vom prinzip
zumindest da da stehen wir dahinter
warum wir sozusagen dann da auch so ein
bisschen so wie von hinten durch die
brust ins auge operieren und glauben
deutschland also man muss ja dann gucken
was im hintergrund wirklich passiert das
ist nicht gut verkauft man könnte sagen
dass es jetzt ein problem ja also olaf
scholz hätte sich hinstellen können
hätte sagen können also nato response
force liefern wir xyz red liefern wir ja
zu den 500 millionen weiß ich nicht was
der deutsche anteil ist also das hätte
man besser verkaufen können aber der
größte anteil kommt irgendwie aus
deutschland dass sie das nicht verkaufen
hat natürlich was wahrscheinlich mit der
deutschen zurückhaltung mit solchen
sachen zu prallen da muss vielleicht
auch noch einiges passieren aber dass da
gar nichts passiert also alle bei aller
kritik die man ansonsten haben kann und
an der späten reaktion haben kann aber
das ist schon mehr als man sich je hätte
einfach vorstellen können und auch
relativ schnell passiert dann vielleicht
ganz gut so ich habe eine kurze zeit
dachte ich sie machen das brillant ja
sie reden von irgendwelchen alten ddr
dinge und die streller ja genau und
stellen die nach vorne und im
hintergrund wirken die fünf im
hintergrund wird geliefert so dass putin
das nicht sieht ja das dachte ich kurz
aber dann habe ich da rein recherchiert
und es ist leider nicht so es ist halt
wirklich nur die strecke angekommen
rostock sie wollten gerade ich wollte
nur sagen man hat ja aus der polnischen
sicht oder aus der mittelosteuropäischen
sich das gefühl dass deutschland mehr
hinterher hinkt sie haben in diesem psv
erwähnt diese 500 millionen es ist
politisch beschlossen worden aber noch
nicht faktisch man wartet wieder auf die
sitzung des bundestages glaube ich am
mittwoch wies man das beschließt also es
dauert die deutsche bürokratie steht
sich da selber im wege sie alle so zäh
und alles so schwierig und auch was die
kommunikation angeht man hat wirklich
das gefühl sie haben sich zurückgelehnt
die deutsche bundesregierung aus der
polnischen sicht gesehen es wurde was
hier nicht aufgearbeitet wurde da gebe
ich ihnen auch recht ist die verfehlte
russland politiker das ist n ja es gab
es gibt gar keine interna der warten da
gibt es also auch
externe oder interne gar keine debatte
darüber was was schwesig schröders et
cetera gemacht hat entschuldigung wenn
ich ein habe 16 jahre bundeskanzlerin
merkel
ich versuche mal wir haben ja gerade
drei kategorien sofort militärisches
eintreten in den ukraine konflikt in der
ukraine krieg ist von
seiten glaube ich hier auch am tisch als
keine option aktuell akzeptiert worden
die frage ist wann ist ein mitgliedsland
angegriffen das wird sicherlich auch auf
dem nato gipfel diskutiert werden es
gibt dazu auch viele fragen auf den in
den sozialen medien tatsächlich machen
sich viele menschen angst um ein
ausbreiten des krieges in europa ohne
jetzt den dritten weltkrieg zu bemühen
aber die fragen sind ja alle sie liegen
auf dem tisch wir haben sie gerade
zitiert zum beispiel fragt jemand kann
nicht ein nicht nato-mitglied mit
westlicher unterstützung der ukraine
helfen stichwort stellvertreterkrieg ein
anderer fragt auf twitter falls polen
angegriffen würde müsste die nato
eingreifen oder nicht schließlich sind
da ja jetzt auch mehr nato soldaten an
den außengrenzen stationiert also wir
kriegen sehr sehr viele fragen zu diesem
mann muss denn die nato mehr tun als sie
jetzt tut
ich glaube wir sind uns am tisch einig
die flugverbotszone die sie gerade auch
als im humanitären also flüchtlings
korridor ist es ja letztendlich
beschrieben haben das wäre schon eine
direkte konfrontation mit russland weil
man müsste sie ja dann diesen korridor
schützen mit flugzeugen und es könnte
dann zu einer eskalation kommen sie
sehen dass alle am tisch hier so klar
und ich glaube deswegen hat kaczynski
diesen vorstoß gemacht um eben über die
auslegung des paragrafen zu reden um
über den fall
in den fall des falles zuzusprechen
damit eben die nato mitgliedsländer und
senator blieb fällt das auf dem auf der
tagesordnung steht dass man nicht dann
überrascht wird sondern auch die
baltischen länder fragen sind für die
nächsten wo macht putin stoppt
dann ja dann aber es sozusagen mich
irritiert halt manchmal auch die
fragestellung dann viele leute oder
sozusagen die haube sorgen es ist wann
gehts uns anfragen nicht wie können wir
jetzt der ukraine helfen und was du
keine und sagt es geht euch am ersten
und am schnellst am kragen wenn ihr uns
jetzt nicht zu mindest maximal
unterstützt
das hat er gesagt in seiner
bundestagsrede
und es kam nur schweigen und also da ist
so eine eine unterschiedliche wie soll
ich sagen emotionalität trüben da
kämpfen menschen um ihr leben wir finden
das schlimm aber dann
diskutieren wir irgendwelche
spiegelstrich und
das scheint mir
vielleicht da noch mal kurz ein haken
also wenn wir jetzt die den
militärischen teil haben wir umrissen
was im moment diskutiert wird wird
sicherlich auch jeden tag wieder eine
neue dynamik reinkommen aber ich zitiere
nochmal die lenz die rede denn abgesehen
von der enttäuschung und den emotionen
die er da gezeigt hat hat er ja auch
unter anderem kritisiert dass es
deutschland eben doch vorrangig um die
wirtschaft geht und an dieser stelle
sind wir jetzt beim rückblick auf die
russlandpolitik der vergangenen 16
merkel jahre um nicht nur nord stream
zwei zu nennen aber natürlich die ganze
energie politik die uns eher abhängig
von russland gemacht hat das heißt auch
jetzt wird ja sehr intensiv darüber
diskutiert energie im margaux jetzt
stärker durchzusetzen gegenüber russland
die usa sind vorangeschritten den fels
auch leichter weil sie längst nicht so
viel energie aus russland beziehen wie
wir sie haben auch in der runde gerade
schon skizziert welche möglichen
kollateralschäden das hätte aber herr
geiger weil sie jetzt gerade so offensiv
gesagt haben wir gucken immer nur was
ist uns jetzt unternehmen wie weit
würden sie jetzt bei den
wirtschaftlichen sanktionen gehen
gashahn zu ja und dann eindeutig was
wären die konsequenzen
vielleicht schlimme konsequenzen für die
deutsche wirtschaft aber wenn wir die
ganze zeit uns das anschauen und dann
ganz viel mitleid haben und dann nicht
eine rezession aus halten wollen dann
weiß ich nicht wir über den spiegel
schauen wollen wir haben man kann sagen
ja die usa haben sie jetzt leichter als
deutschland ja warum haben sie es denn
leichter weise eine klügere bewusstsein
politik auch gemacht hat
deutschland hat die fehlgeleitete
energiepolitik der welt gemacht
deutschland
wenn man es anschaut jetzt auch die
größten opfer bringen für diesen um
diesen krieg zu stoppen das erste wäre
auch zu hören jeden tag hunderte
millionen von euro nach russland
überweisen
dazu sagt ja herr harbecke herr war
genau zu diesem thema im morgenmagazin
vergangene woche befragt worden hat er
gesagt dass diese devisen brauchte putin
gar nicht für den krieg sondern das ist
sind die wiesen aber die kann er damit
kann er ja gar nichts kaufen sondern er
kann den krieg aus seinem eigenen land
heraus finanzieren das heißt herr habeck
stellt zumindest den zusammenhang in
frage zwischen den mehreren hundert
millionen euro die er jeden tag für
energielieferung kriegt und dass er
damit sein krieg finanziert frau bringt
wie sehen sie das
ja das ist wie also dazu müsste man
jetzt wirklich genau wissen was kommt an
diesen milliarden wirklich an und was
kommt ihnen also ich bin keine wird kein
wirtschaftsfachmann und ich werde jetzt
mir echt verkehr helfen irgendwie da war
es was zu sagen aber ich finde das ist
ein bisschen wohlfeil ja weil ich glaube
wir können nicht absehen was es bedeutet
wenn wir wirklich den gashahn komplett
zu drehen und ich finde herr herbig ist
immerhin ein grüner politiker der ja
auch ein bisschen sozusagen aus seinem
aus seiner wohlfühlt zone herausgegangen
ist in einer art und weise die ja
wirklich bemerkenswert ist ja und ganz
klar gesagt hat dass wird solche
konsequenzen haben das wird man sich gut
überlegen dass man das ob man das jetzt
auf gleich macht und ich finde das ist
berechtigt ja also das andere ist ein
moralisches argument und ich würde noch
gar nicht noch mal ein bisschen sagen
was heißt wir tun zu wenig also es ist
ja immer wieder die frage und ich weiß
dass es lästig
momentan wird ja eigentlich fast alles
unternommen was geht ohne einen
unmittelbaren kriegseintritt von
deutschland und der ebel der meinung der
meinung bin ich nicht also das was
machbar ist naja also die 500 millionen
sind ja da und was geliefert wird wird
auch das muss ich wieder zurücknehmen
mit der european
die noch gar nicht beschlossen ist nach
vier wochen ist politisch politisch
beschlossen politiker schlossen
bereits auf bestimmte teile zu greifen
ich finde da sollte man schon verbleiben
formsache
eine formsache ist aber ich wenn sie
sagen habe ist aus seiner komfortzone
heraus gegangen man darf ja nicht
vergessen er war in der ukraine als da
nur frieden war und hat gesagt man muss
dieses land mit waffenlieferungen
das ist finde ich sollte man auch ernst
nehmen wenn er irgendwie davor warnt
jetzt sofort das gasgeschäft abzug
abzuschließen ich gebe ihnen recht das
ist ein riesen moralisches dilemma in
das wir reingeschlittert sind weil wir
eine komplett verfehlte russland politik
gemacht haben über die letzten 16 jahre
und deswegen haben wir einfach nur die
wahl zwischen schlecht sehr schlecht und
ganz schlecht und ich vermute mal wird
noch einiges an diesen
wirtschaftssanktionen drehen da bin ich
davon überzeugt war dass er eine eine
reform ist in der deutschland zumindest
weniger probleme hätte ich sag das mal
ganz vorsichtig und habe er versucht das
auch zu staffeln er hat gesagt erst mal
die kohle da kommen wir glaube ich bis
im herbst raus dann kommt irgendwie das
öl da sind wir glaube ich bis dezember
durch wenn er wenn seine vorhersagen
katar dann gibt es für sich zu haben nur
keine terminals das alles schaffe ich
aber ich bin war mir auch schlecht
vorzustellen ein stabilisiertes europa
mit leuten die da auf der straße stehen
das ist ein szenario was man vielleicht
mal mit denken muss ich gebe ihm vor
ständig recht dass wenn man sowas wie
mario pohl sieht dass man sofort einen
effekt hat dass man sagt da muss doch
jemand was tun aber die vorstellung das
war benzinpreise bekommen von drei euro
irgendwas und dass man dann wirklich ein
soziales problem bekommen was weit über
das hinausgeht was wir jetzt sehen da
sollte man da schon mit denken was du ja
recht wie es die abhängigkeit von polen
energietechnisch und wie blicken sie auf
diese debatte in deutschland die ist
viel höher aus als die abhängigkeit
deutschlands vom von den russischen
rohstoffen trotzdem hat jetzt vorgestern
glaube ich dass ein polnischer politiker
der staatssekretär gesagt polen sei
bereit dieses opfer zu bringen
möchte nicht das blutige regime zu
unterstützen haben wir notiert hier seit
dem anfang des krieges hat deutschland
1,4 milliarden euro nach russland
überwiesen und mag sein dass es nicht
direkt denn krieg finanziert aber
russland so viel ich weiß es von import
abhängig also man braucht bestimmte
dinge muss ins land rollen und da dafür
braucht man das geld ohne dieses geld
wird der krieg nicht
kann ja nicht vorangetrieben werden von
daher aus der deutschen aus der pulle
aus der polnischen sicht sieht man dass
er so dass deutschland nicht bereit ist
jegliches opfer zu tragen gemessen an
den einkommen der bevölkerung in
deutschland ist der benzinpreis nach wie
vor noch relativ niedrig ich weiß es
keine populäre meinung trotzdem wenn man
sich solche tabellen anschaut
einkommensverhältnisse in verschiedenen
europäischen ländern und benzinpreis ist
es in deutschland noch relativ niedrig
und man streitet hier was mich total
geschockt hat man streitet hier es gab
eine meldung von rbb 24 über die
spargelbauern die dann jetzt die dann
jetzt furchtbar leiden weil die ukraine
anstatt dann auf die felder zu kommen an
die front gegangen sind
fällt einem nichts mehr ein tut mir leid
also es ist schon also zurück dazu aus
der polnischen sicht sieht man ja auch
das dann dass die energiewende als
projekt misslungen ist das eben
deutschland sich komplett abhängig
gemacht hat vom russischen gas polen hat
ja versucht schon wenigstens mit dem
baltic pipeline und mit einem lng
terminal ich fürchte arbeitet seit
jahren dass das es unabhängiger wird
wurden von russischen rohstoffen
wir sind fast schon am ende der sendung
ich würde aber trotzdem gerne noch ein
kurzes blitzlicht machen wie geht das
jetzt aus ihrer sicht weiter kann es
irgend ein diplomatisches ende geben es
ist ja für beide seiten geht es um alles
oder nichts haben wir jetzt auch schon
mehrfach gesagt herrscht wirklich was
meinen sie ich bin skeptisch ich höre
immer dass gerade westliche agenturen
und westliche medien immer darauf
anspringen wenn aus russland so ein wort
kommt wie es gebe fortschritte bei den
verhandlungen darauf hat das ja gesagt
und ich frage mich dass meine ich dann
wirklich mit aller bitterkeit macht sich
jemand die mühe die gesamte rede von
hannover durch zuhören man nimmt dann
immer nur diesen einen satz raus auch
den einsatz von wladimir putin ich
erinnere mich gerne an eine russische
freundin immer gesagt hat am schlimmsten
ist die deutsche reaktion wenn irgendwas
anlass zur hoffnung gibt nimmt was sich
dass daraus wenn man sich die gesamte
rede von war of live anhört wenn man
sich die gesamte rede von putin ein dem
luschniki-stadion
gehalten hat wurde in russischen volk
einen sieg versprochen hat dann glaube
ich das ist bitter aber ich glaube daran
dass russland versuchen wird einen
sieger auf dem schlachtfeld zu erringen
und erst danach zu verhandeln alles
andere halte ich für taktische
verzögerungen und möglicherweise auch so
ein bisschen der versuch die westlichen
die westliche diplomatie dazu
desavouieren denn das muss man ja auch
sagen wenn man das russische fernsehen
guckt da kommen wir an jeden tag kommen
drei westliche diplomaten die dann
gezeigt werden die bitten unseren
präsidenten jetzt wieder um frieden aber
die antwort ist ja immer dieselbe das
heißt man lässt er quasi irgendwie die
ganze westliche diplomatie einmal
aufmarschieren ich glaube das ist so ein
bisschen desavouieren wie ich gemeint
habe und ich bin ehrlich gesagt nicht
sehr hoffnungsfroh dass vor einem
militärischen ziel russland auch
wirklich verhandlungen stattfinden
werden leider hat jetzt herrscht klick
ihre zeit mit in anspruch genommen sind
alle ungefähr mit dieser
aber ich bin gespannt auf die reaktion
der amerikaner weil die haben nämlich
ganz klar gemacht dass es nicht ihr
krieg ist ja und ja ohne die amerikaner
wird das keinerlei konzessionen und wird
das auch keinerlei handeln auch der
europäer nicht geben auch der nato nicht
okay danke bis hierhin wir sind jetzt am
ende dieser sendung angekommen das war
unser presseclub es geht weiter mit dem
europamagazin im ersten auch zum krieg
und mit einem interview mit
kommissionspräsidentin ursula von der
leyen auf phoenix und wdr 5 folgt jetzt
presseclub nachgefragt ich wünsche ihnen
noch einen guten sonntag danke
[Musik]
und hier sind wir wieder zurück mit
presseclub nachgefragt auf wdr 5 und
phoenix es geht immer noch um das thema
kampf ums überleben wie kann der westen
die ukraine unterstützen jetzt kommen
unseren nutzerinnen und nutzer zu wort
und ich möchte ganz gerne als erstes zu
georg günther nach eisenach schalten
guten tag und ihre frage bitte schönen
guten tag und die runde ich habe mich
doppelt frage die erste frage ist ist
scheinheilig wenn man auf der einen
seite
das russische erdgas und öl kauft
täglich eine milliarde bezahlt und auf
der anderen seite an die ukraine waffen
liefern damit die ukraine gegen russen
die schädel einschlagen und die russen
bekommen von uns im prinzip des dollars
damit sie den ukrainern die den schädel
einschlagen also das finde ich
unanständig und die zweite frage ist ja
putin lief es ja lieber trotz sanktionen
liefert erdgas erdöl und sowieso steigen
die preise obwohl sich an die
lieferbedingungen nichts geändert hat
wer treibt die preise endlich für das in
meine fragen ich wünsche ihnen noch
einen schönen sonntag ja herr günther
danke auch für ihre offene sprache hier
an der stelle ist nicht ganz was die
wörter die wir jetzt hier benutzen
würden das spannungsfeld zwischen
waffenlieferungen und den
wirtschaftssanktionen haben wir hier
gerade schon beschrieben in der sendung
vielleicht die frage warum steigen die
preise
obwohl geliefert wird es ist halt
nervosität an den märkten
sowie versuchs mal als ehemaliger auch
wirtschaftsredakteur
tatsächlich ist es natürlich im krieg
immer die angst davor dass es zu einer
rezession kommt dass die ganze
wirtschaftliche verflechtung der welt
irgendwie auseinandergerissen wird und
deswegen ist schon allein die angst und
die furcht vor
wirtschaftlichen schwierigkeiten und
noch mehr problemen lässt die preise
steigen
andererseits ist es natürlich und
natürlich fragt man sich auch
wird russland jetzt vielleicht dann doch
stoppen oder werden wir stoppen
inso in und nimmt damit schon auch eine
preissteigerung vorweg ja
aber sozusagen was was die was die
gelieferte menge angeht würde es im
moment noch keine zwingende
preiserhöhung bedeuten müssen danke wir
gehen weiter zu tobias suter in berlin
guten tag und was wollen sie gerne von
der runde ist ja schönen guten tag meine
frage betrifft die waffenlieferung und
zwar würde ich da gerne wissen ob es
nicht möglich ist dass deutschland auf
inoffiziellen wegen mittlerweile schon
viel mehr tut als offiziell bekannt ist
und b ob ein solches vorgehen sich auch
sinnvoll ist um eine eskalation ich
weiteren vorschub zu leisten also sie
vermuten oder wollen wissen ob
möglicherweise im hintergrund viel mehr
passiert bei den waffenlieferungen als
wir jetzt hier wissen und das
geheimhaltungs gründe dafür gibt herr
geiger dich mal übernehmen weil so sagen
ich habe gerade erst gestern abend und
heute morgen genau dazu noch viel
recherchiert und auch einen artikel
geschrieben und muss sagen
es gibt keine hinweise
also sagen ich habe versucht zu gucken
hinter diese streng geheim politik
reinzukommen aber der punkt ist es ist
einfach es läuft so langsam und man
manche dem schließe ich mich nicht an
sagen es läuft so langsam weil
deutschland weil die deutsche politik
zynisch auf eine niederlage der ukraine
spekuliert weil dann hat sie ihre
probleme los ja will ich mich nicht
anschließen ich würde eher glauben es
ist einfach die traurige langsamkeit
unser bürokratie die wir in der korona
krise und in verschiedenen anderen
zusammenhängen gesehen haben und die
jetzt ganz bitter
danke für diese antwort an herrn super
und ich würde gerne zu marc herzog nach
düsseldorf gehen guten tag und wir hören
ihnen zu ja ich möchte gerne folgende
frage stellen warum überlassen wir ein
ganz wichtiges schlachtfeld in diesen
unsäglichen krieg ganz alleine dem herrn
punkten wenn ich das schlachtfeld der
propaganda das schlachtfeld um die
wahrheit und um die unterdrückung der
wahrheit ich will dass ein bisschen
konkretisieren wir haben bei uns
organisationen in deutschland
dass österreich in die kammern oder auch
korrektiv die auf das bild genau belegen
können wie die menschen in der in
russland von den staatsmedien
entschuldigung beschissen werden das ist
für jeden noch so wenig intelligenten
menschen konkret nachvollziehbar was da
gemacht worden ist technisch gemacht
worden ist warum nehmen wir nicht von
den 100 milliarden etwas geld und
investieren darin dass wir diese
unternehmen die das können die so was
beweisen können die sowas belegen können
dass die das dass die das finanziert
werden dass sie das in russischer
sprache machen warum nehmen wir nicht
noch ein bisschen von dem geld dazu und
dann dafür zu sorgen dass diese
dokumentationen über diesen beschluss
über diesen betrug an die russische
bevölkerung herangetragen wird da gibt
es möglichkeiten zu das ist das
fernsehen beispielsweise es gibt aber
auch clevere internet möglichkeiten die
zb von anonymous mal aufgezeigt worden
sind warum investieren wir nicht geld in
diesem
kampf auf der aus dem schlachtfeld der
propaganda warum lassen wir uns davon
herrn putin die die waffen vorschreiben
indem wir selber fertig deutsch und
andere einfach abschalten statt denen
die glaubwürdigkeit komplett zu
zerstören wir sind das du technisch in
der lage die können sagen was sie wollen
ihr sind in der lage zu beweisen dass
die löwen und wie lügen kein mensch
würde ihnen mehr glauben denn war darin
investieren
danke für die präzisierung auch also sie
plädiere nicht dafür dass wir jetzt
selbst westliche propaganda machen
sondern einfach die russische propaganda
eben zu demaskieren frau bringen wollen
sie darauf stellen ja ich glaube das ist
also das ist wirklich eine sache die
auch in der deutschen verantwortung
liegt noch mal was was machen
begrifflichkeiten mit uns ja also putin
hat ja von einer nie dagewesenen
konsequenzen gesprochen ja und das war
ganz klar was er eigentlich damit meint
ja und auch diese hyperschall waffen
alles das wird ja sozusagen ist ja auch
teil seines propaganda krieges das heißt
was macht er er schürt ängste vor einem
atomkrieg und das macht er ganz bewusst
und das macht er in deutschland auch
ganz bewusst weil er weiß dass diese ich
sag jetzt mal ein anfang sein
pazifistische gesellschaft die sich nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg gebildet hat von
nichts mehr angst hat als vor krieg also
es ist ja interessantes wedding dass die
außenministerin von einem bedürfnis nach
sicherheit gesprochen hat und von
wehrhaftigkeit also ich hab gedacht ich
höre nicht richtig ja also das sind
begriffe die zeigen wie tief auch diese
zeitenwende eigentlich auch geht ja und
ich denke das ist ein punkt wo wir
ansetzen könnten dass wir wirklich auch
aufklären ja was das eigentlich heißt
dass wir sauber mit den begriffen
umgehend und nicht auf putins eigentlich
auf putin ausrutschen und sagen moment
mal so weit sind wir doch noch gar nicht
warum macht er das weil er ängste
schüren will und das gelingt ihm ja
wirklich fantastisch wir sind ein
bisschen wie kaninchen vor der schlange
sein oder lieber nichts bevor man etwas
falsches sagt genau das ist einerseits
differenzieren aber andererseits ja auch
die frage wie kommt man denn bei den bei
der russischen bevölkerung die seit
jahren in europa kanada und die
grundfrage die grundfrage ist woran
wohin will ich mich richten da würde ich
eigentlich wird ein teil von dem geld
nehmen und diese die exil russische
community unterstützen die jetzt zum
teil in berlin und in hamburg gelandet
sehr viele fernsehleute mandate nicht
vergessen dass auch viele russen das
land verlassen das ist ein stiller
exotischen aber er findet gerade statt
der formiert sich gerade so was wie so
eine sohn gegen sender das wird im
moment relativ
mit einfachsten mitteln
zusammengestrickt das könnte noch
unterstützen was mich allerdings
erstaunt ist dass sich der kreml selber
nach eigener aussage
propagandistisch im nachteil sieht also
man fühlt sich im moment mit seiner
riesen maschinerie das sind ja hunderte
von millionen rubel die da reingesteckt
werden oder sind sämtliche fernsehsender
die kontrolliert werden internet finde
ich nur interessant für die menschen in
den großstädten ist und relativ wenige
du musst wissen wo du suchst dass sie
sich trotzdem wo sowas wie sein einziges
handy videos auf einmal irgendwie
brüskiert fühlen der dann einfach mit
dem handy raus geht zum fenster und
sagte hier bin ich da wird sofort
dagegen gehalten dass werden diese
gesamten ukrainischen filme die kommen
die werden zerlegt und werden als
angebliche sex analysiert im russischen
fernsehen der sieht man man nimmt das
mittlerweile auch ernst dass davon der
anderen seite was kommt so ganz ohne
weiteres lässt sich das ganze nicht aus
der welt schaffen finde ich also wie
gesagt wenn man wirklich versuchen
wollte irgendwie für die russen was zu
tun unterstützt die exil russischen
fernsehen kannten da sind auch wirklich
große leute dabei die gerade versuchen
so etwas zusammen zu stricken danke auch
für diese zwei perspektiven auf die
frage die eine sehr gute wahl wir gehen
weiter zu bernd schneider nach stuttgart
guten tag und ihre frage bitte am montag
meine frage ist warum muss der westen
den pudding krieg bezahlen es entstehen
riesige kosten für die flüchtlinge für
die waffen und eventuell auch für einen
wiederaufbau der ukraine kann man nicht
das geld was die russische staatsbank im
augenblick bei uns eingefroren hat dafür
verwenden um diese kosten abzudecken
ja das ist eine frage
meinen sie jetzt das in russland
eingefrorene geld da kommt ja
wahrscheinlich gar nicht weggegangen
eingefroren weil sehr viel geld im
augenblick von staatsbank bei uns
eingefroren und beziehungsweise auch das
geld der oligarch ja herr schneider das
ist eine sehr gute frage und herr geiger
möchte gerne hier also tatsächlich
finde ich auch eine sehr charmante idee
und habe ich zum ersten mal gehört von
von meinem kollegen clemens wergin
unserem chef korrespondenten der genau
das auch in einem kommentar gefordert
hat dass man das russische geld nimmt um
reparationen zu bezahlen im fall von dem
krieg problem ist natürlich im moment
noch wer wird diesen krieg gewinnen und
das traurige ist er wenn man zum
beispiel den tschetschenienkrieg
anschaut da hat russland großen die
hauptstadt von tschetschenien ein wunder
schönster mann hier aufgebaut und mit
wunderbaren propaganda bildern der welt
gezeigt jetzt ist tschetschenien
russisch und jetzt ist alles besser
das ist eher das was ich befürchte
sollte die urteilen die diesen krieg
gewinnen so gottes will ein wunder das
wäre ein militärisches wunder wenn ich
herrn experten glauben schenkt auch von
uns ab
dann finde ich das eine charmante idee
wir sind wieder an den
schneider für ihre frage jetzt ist zeit
für unsere nutzerinnen und nutzer und
ich möchte gerne noch albrecht winkler
aus buchen hören guten tag
meine hier wirkte sie können ihre fragen
stehen wir haben eine frage ist die
schönen guten tag
warum eigentlich
gehen die
großbritannien und die usa nicht
oben toten in die ukraine ran wo sie
doch eben das beste am rande um
versprochen haben die grenze der ukraine
zu sichern zusammen mit russland also
das ist doch eine sache also werden doch
die usa und großbritannien wird
vertragsbrüchig das budapester
memorandum genau das ist eine
vereinbarung die ukraine und zwei andere
staaten ihre atomwaffen abgegeben haben
haben sich schutzmächte angeboten warum
tun die jetzt nichts frau bringt naja
das ist die frage das werden die
amerikaner nicht tun weil sie durch den
irak und afghanistan traumatisiert sind
und wenn man sich vorstellt die ukraine
ist ja ich hoffe ich sage keinen
blödsinn aber ich glaube das zweitgrößte
land europas also nach russland also das
ist jetzt nicht irgendwie die schweiz
das heißt wenn man in der ukraine ich
bin jetzt nicht so weit dass ich jetzt
detailliert sagen könnte aber mit 100000
werden sie da nicht zurecht kommen das
heißt man müsste enorme truppen massen
in bewegung setzen und das ist ja nicht
damit getan dass sie reingehen und
meinetwegen das würde wahrscheinlich
funktionieren sie müssen das ja halten
und dass das ist es interessant dass
budapest memorandum hat quasi mein
beistands klausel aber es ist das habe
ich ein entdecktes nicht zu belohnen ist
nicht bösartig
deklaration und kreise
absichtserklärungen eine verpflichtung
das ist das ist der und wenn hätte man
die karte früher ziehen müssen ja
danke dann schaffen wir sogar noch eine
frage und zwar würde ich gerne amélie
sanders aus ahlen in westfalen höheren
guten tag und ihre fragen bitte dann das
guten tag danke dass ich noch zu wort
kommen darf ich hab nur eine ganz kurze
frage ich frage mich warum man im 21
jahrhundert nicht das zustande bringt
das m20 möglich war als die sowjets
berlin west berlin aus sondern wollten
da hat man eine luftbrücke gebaut die
sogenannten rosinenbomber ich habe es
nicht erlebt ich bin danach geboren aber
da hat man west berlin am überleben
gehalten warum ist es nicht möglich
solche flugzeuge jetzt einzusetzen die
russen können ja zu gucken was in die
flugzeuge eingepackt wird das auch keine
einzige waffe drin ist da somit der un
mit roten kreuz und als ich mit dem
militär hilfe leistet und tonnenweise
bei der bevölkerung die verhungert und
leidet etwas abwirft warum ist das nicht
möglich
danke frau sanders also warum gibt es
keine luftbrücke wie damals in berlin
wer möchte darauf antworten wissen sie
was das fürchterliche ist wenn man sich
mit militär beschäftigt das ist
frustrierend ist und dass man immer
sozusagen die herzlichen wahrheiten
aussprechen muss also das ist eine
verletzung des ukrainischen luftraumes
und es werden in die russen nicht
zulassen also sie werden und egal ob da
also abgesehen davon dass ich wage zu
bezweifeln ob man überprüfen lassen kann
was da drin ist und das ist ein schritt
hin zu einer eskalation und deshalb wird
kann das oder die nato ist zumindest
sehr einig dafür sagt wir werden keine
kriegspartei deshalb halte ich das in
der nächsten zeit für ausgeschlossen
jetzt können wir uns noch szenarien
überlegen wo das vielleicht nicht ist
aber das ist eine andere
flugzeuge
jetzt wäre eine verletzung des
ukrainischen luftraums aber die russen
können dann ja und ukrainische welche
von rammstein aus mit dem weg dass neben
hat mir deswegen transportflugzeuge
rosinenbomber ein kleiner rosinenbomber
die viren stellen und dann neben den
punkt wenn du so die piloten aus dem
westen
dass wir nicht mehr irgendwie mit der
kpd zu verhandeln in moskau sondern mit
wladimir putin ich glaube da liegt einer
der gründe
danke wir sind jetzt fast pünktlich am
ende dieses presseclub nachgefragt
vielen dank für ihr interesse und ich
wünsche ihnen jetzt noch einen guten
sonntag bis zum nächsten
[Musik]
unter den linden das politische
streitgespräch aus dem herzen der
hauptstadt
kontrovers sachlich und mit genügend
zeit für jedes argument
der konstruktive meinungsstreit unter
den linden morgen 22 15 bei phoenix
[Musik]
phoenix vor ort
an diesem sonntag aus dem bonner studio
liebe zuschauer herzlich willkommen es
ist tag 25 des krieges russlands gegen
die ukraine dieser krieg ist auch an
diesem tag völkerrechtswidrig und
unvorstellbar brutal er bringt den
ukrainern tod und verzweiflung
beispiel die stadt nikolajew am
schwarzen meer raketenangriff in der
nacht
es sind nur noch trümmer übrig